oui vous êtes capables oui oui vous
savez qu'il ya une chance sur mille pour
qu'ils me répondent oui lorsqu'on met
relation la peine quand même savoir
quand il va j'appelle tout de suite le
président parlera des infos sur la santé
du président la france a peur la france
se dit est-ce que le président va bien
eh ben je vais l'appeler tout de suite
c'est parti et quand bien vous aime bien
il risque de répondre si peu ouais on ne
sait pas mais en tout cas je l'appelle
il n'a pas arrêté les parties c'est
parti je l'appelle non plus ça sonne à
vérifier ans et emmanuel macron à vous
avez le téléphone vous au bout suivant
l'avis du numéro de mettre des anciens
présidents ça s'affiche votre nom je ne
sais pas si ça s'affiche je pense pas
qu'il est le mien moi le moi je suis le
contraire de vous manger les numéros
tout le monde mais personne ne sait que
les appels et chapelles personnes j'ai
laissé un message important
oui un prompt rétablissement au la une
et sur orange et des joints déjà c'est
un indice laissé un message président
s'était cyril hanouna ben voilà on est
en direct on se dit est ce que sarah est
ce que ça va pas là avec avec ce
candidat dont il dira et voilà on y
passent chaque fois on essaie de savoir
si c'est bon si c'est pas bon si ça va
mieux
bien entendu vous savez que je peux
intervenir que j'ai un père médecin il
ya un numéro masqué qui m'appelle alors
d'un président c'est peut-être vous
c'est peut-être les embrasse merci à ben
voilà l'autre a raccroché donc voilà ça
vous allait bien et si je me rappelais
on en direct et vous êtes très heureux
que bruges et de mc ren soit négative et
je suis très heureux que brigitte mâcon
saône et gatif
du point soleil
[Rires]